We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
This caller asks a very relevant question.
Take a listen.
Hey, David.
I was just wondering, whatever happened to
that conga line and bad on brains that we're
supposed to come to an rape and kill us all
or whatever?
I hadn't heard about them in a while.
Right.
What happened to all of the kids that seemed
to have disappeared?
Yeah.
So, of course, that's the immigrant caravan.
The migrant caravan.
It was a big deal leading up to the 2018 midterms.
Then we just didn't hear about it again.
They might bring it back up.
But as you know, Donald Trump doesn't like
to cause panic.
So because Trump doesn't like to cause panic,
I'm sure he wouldn't do something like fear
mongering about a supposed immigrant caravan.
Right.
He would never do because he doesn't want
to cause panic, just like he didn't want to
cause panic about coronavirus.
Yeah.
Now I'm in a punch myself in the face.
Today's bonus show, we will be talking about
what the hell happened during the David Pakman
show vacation.
Don't miss it.
Become a member instantly at join Pacman dot
com.